new in theaters this weekend in Chapter
two what will you see this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
we can't let it happen again the finale
to the Pennywise saga it chapter 2 comes
out this weekend it's been 27 years
since the losers Club bought Pennywise
in the town of Derry most of them have
moved away and moved on with their lives
but children are disappearing again and
they promised to return to defeat
Pennywise if he ever came back now Mike
must bring them all back to Derry and
remind them of what they must do the
cast of the adult losers is incredible
James McAvoy Jessica Chastain Bill Hader
J Ryan James Ransone and Isaiah Mustafa
should have the Old Spice guy on your
side against Pennywise you know I'm
saying hello ladies look at your man now
back to me now back at your man now back
to me this movie is for you if you love
to the first chapter you want to see
what new scares Pennywise comes up with
this time or if you like redheads as
much as I do
and for clarity I'm referring to Jessica
Chastain not penny wise although that is
your weekend ticket what will you see
and check back next week to maybe learn
some pole dancing not for me